I'm Tony Stark
I built neat stuff
I got a great girl and occasionally save
the world so why can't I sleep
you elected me on a single platform I
will defend this country at all costs
the Mandarin must be stopped
you don't know who I am
you'll never see me coming
what are you going to do about these
attacks
the whole world's gonna be watching the
question where is Tony Stark
things are different now I have to
protect the one thing that I can't live
without that's you
which the start
is the first day
it was the left of your life
I'm gonna offer the choice do you want
to life
or a meaningful death
you're not a man
nothing more than maniac I'm not afraid
of you
no politics here
just good old-fashioned revenge
we do need backup that's your department
there's my boys
Wow this movie looks so [ __ ] epic I
cannot wait to watch this film there's
just one too many things to say so let's
give it a shot Tony [ __ ] Stark who
does not love this guy
he's just an overall charming genius
badass but the key to will makes him
work so well
are his underlying layers of emotional
darkness it looks like we get to explore
is even darker sides in part three there
is emotional depth that failed in part
two but it looks like it'll be prevalent
in part three it's great to see a
character in a beloved franchise who
continuously has to face not just new
and terrible bad guys but also have
strong emotional obstacles to overcome
which makes all the flashy stuff that
much more effective from beginning to
end this trailer had me I was drawn to
it it starts off where Tony Stark is
clearly having a bad day he's having a
confusing emotional breakdown where his
life should be perfect yet there's still
emptiness inside of him daddy issues who
really knows what it is
but I'm gonna pay to find out then
there's focus on I believe the President
of the United States they decided not to
make him black and who shows up iron
[ __ ] in Patriots Don Cheadle is back
as the American flag honestly wasn't a
huge fan of Don Cheadle in Iron Man 2 I
mean just look at him clear difference
but through the bits of footage he has
in this trailer
badass brownie points have definitely
gone up for the guy then there's a
terrorist the Mandarin played by Academy
Award winner Ben Kingsley you'll never
see me coming
that's what she said what I love about
this aspect is it immediately makes the
grand scope that much bigger it feels
like now more than ever America really
needs Iron Man
because it's the first real terrorists
that Iron Man is going up against and
who doesn't want to see Iron Man kick
Gandhi's ass I know you do
Plus the Mandarin looks [ __ ] amazing
then Tony starts home is suddenly being
blown
[ __ ] and then there's classic moments
like go-go suits are exploding the Audi
r8 falls into the water single tear
Iron Man suit straps onto him wakes up
in the snow don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening it all looks mysterious
intriguing exciting and with special
effects that exceed expectations the
relationship between Pepper Potts and
Tony Stark looks 10 times more impactful
in this story because it looks like it
plays a very central part there's shots
of her screaming in pain
she's in a broad one point standing in
front of a fire I love this aspect
because Tony Stark is really trying to
protect the love of his life and by him
exposing himself to the world
it puts his love at serious risk because
like the Green Goblin sentence Spider
Man it's ha ha ha oh god Pierce is in it
that's some guy in the movie although
this trailer is super serious
it's a writer director Shane Black who
excels in character-driven action
comedies so I'm sure that fun vibe that
was missing in Iron Man 2 will be
captured in Iron Man 3 god bless america
and that final scene holy [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] are all those Iron Man's Iron Men
let me get straight to the point here
all in all I gotta say
Iron Man 3 could get it right
you
alright guys thanks for checking out the
video please go ahead and go to that
comment box and tell me your points
below and if you don't like the video
well and if you want to see more of my
reviews or if you want to get updated
every time a new review is out go ahead
and subscribe to my channel I'm a link
right there